[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal geh Leute
Berlin am Ende eines langen
demonstrationstages allein in der
Hauptstadt gingen nach Polizeiangaben
bis zu 100.000 Menschen auf die Straße
sie übernmt aufgab guten Abend für all
jene denen die Höhenflüge der AFD und
das immer selbstbewusstere Auftreten von
Rechtsextremisten ein Graus sind waren
die letzten Tage wohl das was man etwas
altertümlich als Balsam für die Seele
bezeichnen könnte die schweigende
Mehrheit sei endlich laut geworden heißt
es jetzt vielfach jene schweigende
Mehrheit die Populisten und radikale
sonst so gerne für sich
reklamieren gestern gingen schon
mindestens 300 000 Menschen auf die
Straße um ihre Haltung gegen
Rechtsextremismus kund zu tun heute
waren es noch mehr allein in München so
viele dass die Veranstaltung abgebrochen
werden musste die Innenstadt wurde
einfach zu voll Stefan leifert und
Alexandra havlin
berichten es sind so Menschen wie Lali
die aus einem Momentum gerade eine
Bewegung Formen Wali ist Mitorganisator
der Münchner Großdemonstration gegen
rechts die am Ende alle Erwartungen
übertraf es hat mich unfassbar
überrascht ich dachte das wird
vielleicht eine kleine
Kundgebung wo vielleicht höchstens 1000
2000 Leute kommen laut Polizei kamen am
Ende über 100.000 laut Veranstaltern gar
250 000 jedenfalls so viele dass die
Demo wegen Überfüllung abgebrochen
werden musste die letzten AFD
Enthüllungen haben ein Ventil geöffnet
dass es gerade ums große Ganze geht ist
die Sorge die mobilisiert Menschen die
sonst wenig Neigung zum Demonstrieren
haben säumen die
Straßen ich bin sehr sehr selten auf
Demonstrationen aber ich glaube das ist
heute ein Punkt wo man einfach mal dabei
sein sollte und zeigen sollte dass man
auch gegen diese Entwicklung in
Deutschland ist meine Motivation ist
tatsächlich in Deutschland und Europa
die Demokratie zu verteidigen wir sind
Bund und Deutschland soll Bund bleiben
Bund sein und
unsere Kinder sollen in einem Land
aufwachsen wo ja jeder sein darf wie wie
er ist und wo die Türen offen stehen
über ganz Deutschland ziehen sich auch
an diesem Wochenende die Proteste gegen
AFD und Rechtsextremismus rund 90
Veranstaltungen waren angemeldet
darunter viele im Osten auch in kotbus
einer Hochburg der Neonaziszene kamen
tausende darunter der Ministerpräsident
ich stehe hier oben und ich habe tränne
in den
Augen es ist
unglaublich was hier heute passiert
die Lausitz steht auf die Lausitz steht
auf für
Demokratie über eine Million Menschen
sind an diesem Wochenende Deutschland
weit auf den Beinen in Dresden der
einstigen pegider Hochburg kamen heute
50000 Menschen um sich dem drohenden
Rechtsruck
entgegenzustellen ich glaube es aber
doch eentlich eher der Anhaltspunkt dass
viele Leute das Gefühl haben hier
entgleitet ein was und man möchte wieder
zeigen dass died nicht die Mitte der
Gesellschaft darstellt es isteg geraten
in Deutschland die schweigende Mehrheit
wird plötzlich sichtbar und hörbar es
zeigt dass die Zivilgesellschaft
deutlich stärker ist als wir es manchmal
wahrnehmen sie kommt immer dann ins
Spiel wenn riskante Situation für die
Demokratie auftreten und das ist ein
gutes Zeichen wir haben eine Demokratie
mit Demokraten und DemokratInnen das
unterscheidet uns eindeutig von Weimar
und wir soll mit diesen komischen
vergleichen auch sehr vorsichtig sein in
die große Demo von München mischte sich
im Vorfeld ein kleiner Streit zwischen
den Veranstaltern und Bayerns
Regierungsparteien Hubert eiwanger ließ
wissen erhte die Demos vielfach für
linksextrem unterwandert was seine
Parteifreunde nicht vom kommen abhielt
ich würde ihn raten und ich würde sagen
F schön wenn er auch dann da mal da ist
aber ich glaube es gibt im Land jetzt
auch genauso viel Demonstrationen gegen
Rechts und da wird sich für ihn schon
die Gelegenheit bieten auf der Bühne
wurden nicht nur eiwanger und CSU für
unerwünscht erklärt manche Redner warfen
auch die ampelparteien in einen Topf mit
der AFD doch das kleine Karo zwischen
Veranstaltern und Parteien konnte das
große Zeichen nicht trüben München zeigt
heute dass die Mehrheit nicht mehr
schweigt Diana Zimmermann in Berlin wenn
man sich jetzt mal so die politischen
Reaktionen auf diese Massendemos ansieht
dann hat man ja schon den Eindruck da
gibt's insgesamt doch eine ja
parteiübergreifende Gemeinsamkeit die
man selten hat oh ja bis auf die AFD
naturgemäß haben sich alle im Bundestag
vertretenden Parteien positiv bis
geradezu begeistert geäußert bei manchen
Politikern hat man den Eindruck dass sie
geradezu erleichtert sind darüber dass
sie den Kampf mit der AFD nicht alleine
aufnehmen müssen denn ganz offenkundig
haben sich ja so viele Menschen lange
das erstärken der AFD angeschaut und nun
beschlossen auf die Straße zu gehen mal
nicht gegen die regierungsp Politik
sondern für Demokratie und Offenheit
allerdings stellen sich für die Politik
in den kommenden Wochen auch einige
Fragen aus diesen Demonstrationen
nämlich erstens was wollen sie selbst
dagegen tun dass die AFD weiter stärker
wird werden die demokratischen Parteien
damitte aufhören sich gegenseitig dafür
zu beschuldigen dass die AFD so stark
geworden ist werden sie aufhören mit
populistischen Parolen auf wlerfang zu
gehen soass früher unsagbares langsam
normal wird die Ampel möchte der AFD den
Zustrom der unzufriedenen abdrehen indem
sie künftig geräuschlöser regiert das
allerdings hat sie schon häufig
versprochen und nie lange gehalten danke
schön Diana nach Berlin
abfehrbereit nach innen zu sein gegen
extremistische Umtriebe und ihre
umsturzfantasien das ist das eine die
andere Frage ist wie Abwehr oder
verteidigungsbereit Deutschland und
Europa nach außen sind wobei das eine
mit dem anderen ja durchaus
zusammenhängt man schaue nur auf die USA
dass Putin darauf hofft dass im November
ein US-Präsident Donald Trump auf die
Weltbühne zurückkehrt ist offensichtlich
in Europa befürchtet man ja dass das die
NATO erheblich schwächen ja vielleicht
sogar zerstören könnte auch deshalb
warnt der deutsche Verteidigungsminister
davor dass Russland in einigen Jahren
auch natoländer angreifen könnte ich
habe Boris Pistorius vorhin gefragt was
er damit genau meint und was er in
seinem ersten Amtsjahr für die
Bundeswehr erreicht hat dazu vorab einen
Bericht von Ines
TRS der Krieg ist zurück in Europa für
die Bundeswehr genauso wie für unsere
Gesellschaft bedeutet das wir müssen
kriegstüchtig werden es geht darum dass
wir uns mit klarem nüchternen Blick auf
den Ernstfall vorbereiten
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius will
kriegstüchtig werden um abzuschrecken
und gewappnet zu sein F bis Jahre so
Pistorius blieben uns bis Putin einen
natostaat angreifen könnte der Zeitdruck
ist größer als i Pistorius benennt ich
spreche eher von 3 bis 5 Jahren weil
Russland nicht nur die Drohungen weiter
eskalieren lässt insbesondere gegen
Lettland aber auch die anderen
baltischen Staaten gegen Moldau sondern
weil Russland auf Kriegswirtschaft
umgestellt hat die Bundeswehr dagegen
derzeit eher nicht verteidigungsbereit
es fehlt an Gerät Munition und Personal
stand sie vor der Zeitenwende blank da
ist sie heute gar Blanka eine
grundlegende Reform der Beschaffung
steht noch aus der Zustand ist im
letzten Jahr in den letzten zwei Jahren
nicht besser geworden weil wir zu wenig
produzieren weil wir sehr viel an die
Ukraine abgeben müssen und die
Bundeswehr ist nicht kriegstüchtiger
geworden das ist der Lage geschuldet
aber wir müssen einfach Tempo machen
nicht uns läuft die Zeit weg und die
mentale Zeitenwende ist die neue
Bedrohungslage angekommen in den Köpfen
von Politik und Gesellschaft ein Ruck
ging durchs Land beim russischen Angriff
auf die Ukraine zwei Jahre später nicht
der Moment die Bedrohung zu
verhamlosen wir müssen whrfähig werden
wir müssen den Willen haben auch in der
Bevölkerung unser Land zu verteidigen
und wir brauchen eine Industrie die in
der Lage ist die Forderung der
Bundeswehr auch zu erfüllen die
Gewährleistung unseres Friedens unserer
Freiheit ist nicht allein Aufgabe der
Bundeswehr sondern eine Aufgabe der
gesamten deutschen Gesellschaft da sind
auch zivile gefragt beispielsweise der
Gesundheitsbereich aber auch der ganze
Bereich der Katastrophenhilfe des
Bevölkerungsschutzes da ist noch eine
Menge zu tun und das muss als Aufgabe
aller gesehen werden Pistorius will eine
kriegstüchtige Truppe auf Widerstand
stößt er immer wieder beim Kanzler und
beim linken SPD Parteiflügel Milliarden
schwere Umschichtungen im Haushalt zur
Verteidigung werden in den nächsten
Jahren nötig da geht nicht jeder
Parteifreund mit möglicherweise wird die
Welt ja auch friedfertiger sein als die
Pessimisten das jetzt erwarten wir
werden das Sehen ich halte nichts von
Kassandra rufen die für die nächsten 10
Jahre schon vorus ausgebracht werden
doch schafft Trump es erneut ins Weiße
Haus könnte schon bald der NATO
Schutzschirm fehlen einen Notfallplan
haben dafür weder Brüssel noch Berlin
die Haltung die die Politik zu zeig hat
ist ja
ja
schon eine Gefahr aufgrund der
Weltpolitik aber wir fahren eigentlich
wie bisher wir wursteln uns so ein
bisschen durch und es wird schon nicht
zum Schlimmsten kommen wir wissen nicht
was passiert aber es ist ein
hochrisikokurs den sie fahren ein Jahr
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius eine
neue Wehrhaftigkeit im Denken und im
Handeln fordert er viel Zeit bleibt
nicht und der
Bundesverteidigungsminister ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr frius
guten Abend Frau Slomka sind jetzt
ziemlich genau ein Jahr im Amt und haben
sich in der Zeit ja einen Namen damit
gemacht Dinge auszusprechen die andere
nicht mal denken wollen jetzt haben sie
z.B davor gewarnt dass sich die
natooländer auf einen russischen Angriff
auf auf auch auf ihr Territorium
einrichten müssen an was für Szenarien
denken sie denn da es geht weniger darum
sich konkret auf einen Angriff
vorzubereiten oder einzurichten aber
damit rechnen muss man und wenn man mit
etwas rechnen muss ich auf eine Gefahr
einstellen muss von der man nicht weiß
ob und wann sie eintritt dann heißt das
man muss sich dafür wappnen und das tun
wir gerade gemeinsam mit den Alliierten
in der NATO und das ist auch notwendig
also man kann sich ja durchaus konkrete
Szenarien vorstellen z.B im Baltikum da
wird dann ein Aufstand der rüischen
Minderheit inszeniert dann greift
baltisches Militär ein dann heißt es aus
russischer Seite müssen unsere Leute
schützen und dann rollen eventuell
Panzer und fliegen Kampfhubschrauber das
wäre dann eigentlich genau der Moment wo
dann auch die deutsche litaauen
bririgade zum Einsatz käme oder na ja
das ist genau der Punkt deswegen stellen
wir die ja auf um gleich vor Ort präsent
zu sein mit dieser Brigade und die wird
27 einsatzbereit sein aber sol lange
braucht es um die Brigade aufzustellen
deswegen sagen wir ja immer die
Militärexperten gehen von einem Zeitraum
von mehreren Jahren aus die es braucht
bis Russland überhaupt wieder in der
Lage wäre das ist eine Schätzung genau
wissen tut das niemand und diese Zeit
müssen wir die nächsten dre bis 5 Jahre
müssen wir intensiv nutzen um uns zu
wappnen und sagt der Inspekteur des
Heeres jetzt schon wir haben eigentlich
gar nicht genug Leute und auch nicht
genug Material um diese Brigade zu
bestücken die kann ja auch nicht 2027
plötzlich aufploppen das muss ja jetzt
eigentlich losgehen aber dafür ist die
Bundeswehr noch gar nicht ausgerüstet
nee das ist nicht ganz richtig wir
beschaffen ja gerade in großem Stil und
mit hoher Geschwindigkeit wir haben
alleine im Jahr
2023 mehr 25 Millionen Euro Vorlagen in
den Haushaltsausschuss eingebracht als
jemals zuvor über 50 und im nächsten
Jahr werden wir vielleicht sogar
dreistellig werden das heißt wir haben
das Tempo bei der Beschaffung deutlich
erhöht und gleichzeitig gehört eben dann
auch dazu sich einzugestehen wir können
schneller bestellen aber der zweite
Schritt ist die Industrie muss schneller
produzieren und darüber sind wir im
Gespräch Industrie sagt aber dass sie
auch viele Aufträge bislang nicht
bekommen hat ja das ist mir neu also in
allen relevanten Bereichen das gilt für
Munition das gilt für gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge und vieles andere mehr
Artillerie und patreot Systeme sind die
auf der die Aufträge raus oder in
unmittelbarer Vorbereitung wir geben
richtig Gas wenn man sich das jetzt mal
aber trotzdem mal konkret in Litauen
angschaut und die Bri Gade müsste jetzt
schon loslegen dann hätte die analoge
Funkgeräte mit denen sie sich mit den
anderen Europäern gar nicht verständigen
kann und die Panzer die dann da rollen
würden könnten zweich tolle Leopard 2
sein aber es gäbe keine Heeres
Flugabwehr die diese Panzer schützen
würde und das haben wir jetzt mal der
Ukraine gesehen was das dann bedeutet
wenn man nicht genügend Luftabwehr hat
Flugabwehr hat jetzt Rechen sich
haushaltstechnisch begründete
Entscheidung von vor einigen Jahren als
man die heresflugabwehr ersatzlos
abgeschafft hat das müssen wir jetzt
wieder aufbauen mit völlig neuem Gerät
aber auch da sind wir dabei aber klar
muss auch sein der Krieg gegen die
Ukraine dieser furchtbare Krieg geht ins
dritte Jahr das heißt vor zwei Jahren
hat er begonnen äh und in dieser Zeit
haben wir viel geschafft aber wir können
nicht in zwei Jahren die kertwende eins
zu ein vollziehen und aufholen auf den
Stand den wir eigentlich bräuchten in
einer Zeit die einfach zu kurz dafür war
aber dass wir jetzt im Ende des zweiten
Kriegsjahres sind und die Europäer nicht
in der Lage sind der Ukraine genügend
Munition artilleri Munition zu
beschaffen also dass das versprochene
Ziel nicht mal erreicht wird das spricht
jetzt eigentlich nicht dafür dass man
sehr viel begriffen hat vor zwei Jahren
und sehr viel unternommen hat na ja der
diese munitionsinitiative ist etwa ein
knappes Jahr alt ich habe damals davor
gewarnt dass das eine hohe Erwartung ist
die man damit wegt und sehr wohl im Auge
behalten muss ob denn die
Rüstungsindustrie dazu überhaupt so
schnell in der Lage sein würde und es
zeigt sich dass S es nicht war nicht
sein konnte weil die Kapazitäten die
Produktionskapazitäten einfach noch
nicht da sind sie wachsen auf aber auch
das geht jetzt nicht das geht nicht von
jetzt auf gleich das sind alles die
Baustellen auf denen wir mit Hochdruck
arbeiten mit der Industrie zusammen wir
sind sehr kooperativ mit denen unterwegs
die wissen worauf es ankommt aber dazu
gehört auch dass wir als Bundesregierung
dass ich als Verteidigungsminister die
Mittel habe um langfristige Bestellung
aufzugeben die dann wiederum die
Planungssicherheit auch für die
Industrie bedeuten ja sie wollten z.B 10
Milliarden mehr im regulären werita
bekommen haben sie im rund
1,8 ja das ist so so ist das in der
Politik wenn es um Haushalt geht
gleichzeitig haben wir aber das
Sondervermögen und mit diesem sonder mit
Hilfe dieses Sondervermögens kommen wir
in diesem Jahr ähm auf über 73
Milliarden Euro insgesamt Ausgaben für
Rüstung und das ist der höchste Betrag
den es jemals gab und er wird weiter
steigen müssen das wissen alle 2027 ist
dieser Topf
alle ja auch das ist keine neue
Erkenntnis das ist völlig richtig und
alle wissen dass ab 27 der et dann der
eigentliche et des
Verteidigungsministeriums aufwachsen
muss darüber werden sich jetzt die
Haushaltsexperten in diesem und dem
kommenden Jahr Gedanken machen weil
natürlich sich gestellt sein muss dass
wir auch über die jahresgrenzen der
jeweiligen Haushalte hinaus planen und
beschaffen können weil wir noch lange
nicht am Ende dessen sind was wir
brauchen jetzt ist es so die Zuschauer
die uns jetzt zuhören wie wir über
Granaten und taubitzen und und und
Heeres Flugabwehr und ähnliches reden
von denen wird ein Teil mit dem Kopf
nicken und sagen ja ja ja das muss alles
jetzt viel schneller gehen aber es wird
auch ein großer Teil das als Graus
empfinden und das auch für falsch halten
und für etwas was eher die Sache noch
viel gefährlicher macht wenn jetzt
massiv aufgerüstet wird wird wie wollen
Sie diesen Teile der Bevölkerung da
mitnehmen zunächst mal würde ich sagen
ich habe für jeden Verständnis der sich
dabei unwohl fühlt dass mehr Waffen
Besch beschafft werden das verstehe ich
menschlich und emotional sehr wohl aber
die Erfahrung aus der Geschichte des
Kalten Krieges und die Situation die wir
jetzt haben mit diesem putin ist viel
unberechenbarer lehrt eben auch dass
Abschreckung das einzig wirksame Mittel
ist um sich gegen einen möglichen
Aggressor von vorne rein
zu positionieren sozusagen Greif uns
nicht an wir werden in der Lage sein und
willend sein und zu verteidigen wenn man
das aber will muss man auch die Mittel
dafür haben und das heißt man muss
glaubhaft abschrecken um zu verhindern
dass es überhaupt zu einem
kriegsausbrich Ausbruch kommt diese
Logik wird aber auch von Teilen ihrer
eigenen Partei nicht geteilt also Herr
Mützen nicht bekommt schon die Krise
wenn sie von kriegstüchtigkeit sprechen
also ich glaube er steht voll hinter den
Ausgaben die wir tätigen müssen dass
sich einige an dem Wort kriegstüchtig
stören verstehe ich aber im Grunde
genommen ich kann es nur wiederholen
bedeutet Tüchtigkeit laut Deutschem
Duden nicht mehr als eine besondere Form
der Tauglichkeit es geht also darum dass
wir uns in die Lage versetzen müssen
einen Krieg äh zu führen der uns
aufgezwungen wird keinen den wir
beginnen das versteht sich von selbst
aber wenn wir angegriffen werden müssen
wir Krieg führen können äh und das ist
das entscheiden und darauf müssen wir
uns vorbereiten also die Formel lautet
Krieg führen zu können um keinen Krieg
führen zu müssen Herr Pistorius danke
für das Gespräch sehr gerne Frau
slamker das Interview haben wir vor
einer guten Stunde geführt online auf ZF
heute finden Sie dazu noch ein Gespräch
mit dem Militärhistoriker sünke neizel
der darin sehr konkret erläutert warum
die Bundeswehr derzeit nicht
kriegstüchtig oder verteidigungsfähig
ist zu den Eigentümlichkeiten des
russischen Regimes gehört es ja dass es
zwar einerseits mit mafiösen Methoden
einen kapitalistischen oligarchenstaat
geschaffen hat mit unfassbarem Reichtum
für einige wenige gleichzeitig huldigt
Putin aber der istischen Sowjetzeit
speziell Genosse Diktator Stalin aber
auch dessen Wegbereiter der Tote Lenin
liegt immer noch aufgebahrt und
einbalsamiert in seinem Mausoleum in
Moskau dort wird heute an seinen
hundersten Todestag erinnert Amin Körper
berichtet aus
Moskau ausländische Medien sind an
diesem historischen Tag unerwünscht nur
am Eingang zum Roten Platz können wir
filmen Zeremonie und Reden der
Kommunisten finden ohne stad es sind
auch nur ein paar hundert gekommen um
Lenin zu
gedenken der liegt im eigens für ihn
gebauten Mausoleum auf dem Roten Platz
Vladimir iljit uljanov besser bekannt
als Lenin 100 Jahre liegt er schon hier
mancher fragt sich
warum denn der heutige Herrscher
Russlands schätzt ihn nicht besonders
Präsident Putin hat eine eigene
Geschichtserzählung entwickelt in der
Lenin nicht gut
wegkommt
die Anführer im Donbass hatten sich als
die Sowjetunion gegründet wurde nicht
als Teil der ukrainischen Teilrepublik
gesehen aber lenin hatte beschlossen wie
er sich ausdrückt und das ist ein Zitat
anders zu entscheiden und hat sie der
Ukraine
übergeben Moskau Lenin hat sie zur
Hauptstadt gemacht eines Weltreichs von
der eine Weltrevolution ausgehen sollte
zu der es am Ende nicht kam
trotzdem gehört Lenin heute zu Moskau
wie der Schnee zum Winter der ihn
umhüllt auch nach dem verlorenen Kalten
Krieg und dem Ende der kommunistischen
Idee Lenin ist irgendwie geblieben
nikita petov ist Historiker bei der
Organisation Memorial die die Verbrechen
der sowjeta aufarbeitet und mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis geehrt
wurde wir haben heute ein nicht
vergessen Lenins er ist nicht vergessen
er ist aber sozusagen in ein
ell er wird jetzt in die Reihe der
Antihelden
eingeordnet Lenin zu Grabe getragen vor
h Jahren und doch bis heute konserviert
nachdem er die Herrschaft der zahren
zugunsten einer der Arbeiter und Bauern
beendete und dafür das Land mit dem
roten Terror überzog der von seinem
Nachfolger Stalin noch übertroffen
[Musik]
wurde Zahlen im Unterschied zum Terror
des Stalinismus wie viele Menschen
während des roten Terrors ums Leben
kamen wir verstecken das Problem und
fegen den Dreck unter den
Teppich und so ist die Aufarbeitung
genauso auf der Strecke geblieben wie
Lenin im Mausoleum über die Hälfte der
Russen will ihn unter der Erde sehen und
sein Kapitel beenden doch dafür müsste
man an ihm rühren und Debatten sind
unerwünscht im neuen Russland im
Russland Vladimir
Putins und in den Nachrichten geht der
Blick jetzt erstmal wieder nach Berlin
Heinz in der Koalition gibt es
Unstimmigkeiten wegen einer Erhöhung des
Kinderfreibetrags bei der FDP heißt es
Finanzminister Lindners Plan nur den
Kinderfreibetrag zu erhöhen das
Kindergeld aber nicht sei abgesprochen
mit dem Kanzler selbst und man verweist
darauf dass das Kindergeld im
vergangenen Jahr bereits erhöht worden
sei SPD Chef klingball sagte der Bild am
Sonntag er halte es für ungerecht nur
Familien mit sehr hohem Einkommen zu
entlasten gerade die arbeitende Mitte
sollte entlastet werden ähnlich äußerte
sich die Grünen Fraktionsvorsitzende
dröge im Interview mit der ZDF-Sendung
Berlin direkt aus meiner Sicht haben wir
in der Ampel sehr klar verabredet dass
Kinderfreibetrag und Kindergeld in
gleichem Maße steigen sollen dass man
nicht das eine anheben kann ohne das
andere zu lassen das wäre nicht gerecht
denn den Kinderfreibetrag kriegen sehr
reiche Eltern für ihre Kinder das
Kindergeld kriegt die Mitte der
Gesellschaft und warum sollte ich jetzt
ausgerechnet die Kinder von sehr reichen
Menschen besser unterstützen als die der
Polizistinnen und
Krankenpfleger gut 40% der Rentnerinnen
und Rentner in Deutschland müssen mit
einem Nettoeinkommen von weniger als
1250 € im Monat auskommen das betrifft
knapp 7,5 Millionen Menschen rund zwei
Drittel von ihnen sind Frauen wie aus
Berechnungen des Statistischen
Bundesamtes
hervorgeht im Rennen um die
Präsidentschaft Kandidatur der
us-reublikaner hat Ex-Präsident Trump
einen Konkurrenten weniger Floridas
Gouverneur rond de santtis gab am Abend
seinen Rückzug bekannt er war bei der
Vorwahl in Iowa Zweiter hinter Trump
geworden mit deutlichem Abstand
desenttis kündigte an nun Trump zu
unterstützen schon seit Tagen befinden
sich weite Teile der USA fest im Griff
arktischer Kälte durch Unterkühlung und
Unfälle kamen bislang mindestens 67
Menschen s Leben wie hier in Nebraska
und auch noch weiter südlich herrschen
viele Orts teils zweistellige Minusgrade
eisige Temperaturen auch auf dem Times
Square in New York W für die kommende
Woche versprechen Meteorologen
Entspannung dann soll der Polarluft
Zustrom
abbrechen ein seltenes Naturschauspiel
war in der vergangenen Nacht im Osten
Deutschlands zu sehen ein Asteroid
verglühte beim Eintritt in die
Erdatmosphäre Aufnahmen zeigen wie ein
Feuerball kurz hell aufleuchtet und dann
offenbar verglüht der Asteroid hatte
eine Durchmesser von etwa 1 m Schäden
oder Verletzte durch herabstürzende
Gesteinsbrocken sind bislang nicht
bekannt waren sie schon mal in Bad
ischel nicht zu verwechseln mit ischkel
dem österreichischen Skiort der zu
Beginn der coronapandemie für
schlagzeahen sorgte Bad ischel ist der
zentrale Urlaubsort im Salzkammergut das
in diesem Jahr als europäische
Kulturhauptstadt ausgewählt wurde die
ganze Region so ähnlich wie 2010 das
rohrgebiet wie man sich im Salzkammergut
darauf vorbereitet hat und dabei mehr
sein will als eine
postkartenidillele das berichtet
Christian von
Rechenberg Salzkammergut Kultur
Hauptstadt das ist eine ganze Region ist
merkt man sobald man sie erreicht Kunst
aller Orten am Traunsee etwa schwimmt
ein Sauna eine
Installation wir haben uns gedacht dass
wir gerne diesen Raum schaffen möchten
um auch im Winter Möglichkeit haben um
über die raumpolitischen Themen von
kmunden und vom draunsee reden zu können
Bart ischel das Zentrum der
Kulturhauptstadt steht stellvertretend
für 23 Gemeinden die Stadt ein
Schmuckkästchen wird dieser Tage selbst
zum Kunstwerk und nicht alles was die
Künstler so aufbauen oder enthüllen
versteht man auf den ersten Blick
aber genau darum geht's nachdenken
diskutieren auch über diese
Musikmaschine die daran erinnern will
dass das Salzkammer gut einst
Sommerfrische der Avangard war Klang
[Musik]
Installation auch bei der
Eröffnungsfeier gestern ein Jodler aus
Taus Kehlen geleitet von Hubert von
[Musik]
geuser die Sprache der Berge Brauchtum
und jetzt kommt frischer
Wind
Veränderungen machen viele Leute nervös
und
ängstlich und natürlich ist so ein
kulturhauptstatt ja da verändert sich
was
da bleibt
eigentlich nichts
unbewegt und daher ist es Bein
zwingend Wurst im siss Style Auftritt
Homage an eine starke Frau doch er will
eben auch Rütteln am Klischee der K und
K Kult B ischel lebt davon gut sogar
doch es ist Identität und Hypothek
gleichermaßen Thema Massentourismus die
Kulturhauptstadt will sich und ihre
Tradition feiern aber auch
hinterfragen wie gehen wir mit
Ressourcen um welche Zukunft hat das
heimische Handwerk was sind unsere Werte
und
Salz ist so eine Wurzel es hat das
Salzkammer gut reich gemacht nun soll
Kultur das neue Salz sein viele
Ausstellungen und Installationen setzen
sich damit
auseinander meine Performance hält das
Salz in Bewegung es bilden sich
andauernd neue Schichten die immer
wieder zerfließen und sich mit dem Stein
ganz langsam
Vereinen ein Jahr zeigt sich das
Salzkammergut zugänglich
nachdenklich und von seiner schönsten
Seite Quali noch mal weiter mit dem
Sport an diesem Wochenende zunächst mit
zwei Ergebnissen aus der Fußball
buundesliga da hat Bayern München zu
Hause gegen Werder Bremen verloren 0 Z1
und auch im zweiten Sonntagsspiel ging
der Gast als Sieger vom Platz der FC
Augsburg gewinnt in möncheng glladbach
1:2 Skirennfahrer Linus strasser hat
sensationell den Weltcup slalum von
kitzbül gewonnen der 31-Jährige Münchner
fuhr am berühmten ganslerhang dank eines
starken zweiten Laufes zum Erfolg
Strasse verwies Christopher Jakobsen aus
Schweden und den Schweizer Daniel JUH
auf die weiteren Plätze es ist der erste
deutsche torlauftriumph in kitsbülll
seit Felix neuruter
2014 weiter zum Skisprung Weltcup im
polnischen sakopane dort konnte der
Österreicher Stefan Kraft seinen schon
siebten saisonseg feiern aber auch
Andreas Wellinger konnte sich freuen
nach seinem ersten Sprung auf Platz 6
gelang ihm mit einem 137 m Sprung noch
die Aufholjagd und am Ende landet er auf
Rang 2 weiter geht es für Wellinger und
die DSV Adler kommende Woche bei der
skiflug WM
ad
Mitterndorf so gleich gibt's noch die
Wetteraussichten aber zuvor hat Carolina
Freitag noch unseren sonntäglichen
Ausblick auf die neue Woche die mit
einem Abschied
beginnt er prägte die deutsche
Bundespolitik über Jahrzehnte als
Volksvertreter als Architekt der
deutschen Einheit als cdu-pitiker am
Montag wird die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland Wolfgang Schäuble mit einem
trauerstaatsakt würdigen Schäuble war am
zweiten Weihnachtstag
gestorben die evangelische Kirche will
Fälle sexualisierter Gewalt und ander
missbrauchsformen in ihren Reihen
aufarbeiten dabei helfen soll eine erste
bundesweite Studie die ein unabhängiges
Forscherteam am Donnerstag vorstellen
wird die EKD hatte die Studie Ende 2020
in Auftrag gegeben auch Betroffene waren
an ihr
beteiligt mit Veranstaltungen und
Aktionen wird rund um den Jahrestag der
Befreiung des Konzentrationslagers
Auschwitz an die Millionen
holokaustopfer erinnert am Samstag sucht
bundesinnenministerin fäser die
Gedenkstätte Ravensbrück auf deren
Gelände sich das größte KZ für Frauen
sowie ein Männerlager
befanden zwei Wochen nach der
offiziellen Gründung der
wagenknechtpartei BSW werden die rund
450 erstmitglieder am Samstag in Berlin
zum ersten Bundesparteitag
zusammenkommen dort wollen sie unter
anderem den Entwurf zum
europawahlprogramm
Besprechen noch mal kurz zurück zur
Fußball Bundesliga da ging es bei einem
Ergebnis etwas durcheinander um es noch
mal klar zu sagen der FC Augsburg hat
2:1 gegen Borussia Mönchen Gladbach
gewonnen und jetzt die Wetteraussichten
morgen viele Wolken und zeitweise Regen
dabei vor allem im Südosten
vorübergehend Glatteis möglich
stürmischer Südwestwind an der Nordsee
und auf den Bergen orkanwöhen 4 bis 11°
in den nächsten Tagen sehr mild und
wechselhaft am Mittwoch verbreitet
sturmböhen bei Höchstwerten zwischen
vier und 14° starkes
Tauwetter das war's von uns am Ende
dieser Woche gleich geht's mit Inspektor
Barnaby weiter und die nächste heute
Express gibt's dann um 0:30 Uhr ja Heinz
ist morgen auch wieder hier aber an
diesem Platz erwartet sie dann Christian
sieas auf Wiedersehen bis
[Musik]
morgen